mensch hallo ich habe mir gerade den
ball aufgepumpt und damit herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren zu einer neuen episode von luca
reagiert das ist ein format wo ich euch
auf twitter schreiber haye steht welche
dummen videos von euch und ihr schickt
mir dumme videos und auf die reagiert
dann hallo luca ich habe zwar nichts du
musst gefunden aber ich bin schon dumm
genug um in dein video mitzumachen
fast alte das ist tatsächlich eine sache
die ich auch von mir behaupten kann also
ja ich bin auch sehr dumm aber wir
machen direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
video idee katja ich laufe hier nur so
rum
o freunde das aufmerksame mitglied der
luke crew weiß schon dass das die stimme
vom horror huhn war und das hormon ist
ein huhn aber irgendwie auch ein mensch
das ist auf jeden fall ein charakter der
mir immer wenn ich sage schicken dumme
videos zu flug reagiert videos
einschickt und jetzt hat er wohl eine
dicke lippen katja parodie gemacht also
film ab bisher geht das ganze noch gut
klar also wir haben einen beat der ein
bisschen anders ist als der von katja
wilke das heißt ein bisschen der war
komplett anders aber ich bin auf jeden
fall gespannt wo das ganze hingeht
[Musik]
es ist also wirklich eine dicke lippen
parodie vom horror holen das habe ich ja
vorhin noch vermutet aber jetzt wird mir
klar auf was wir uns hier gerade
eigentlich einlassen
[Musik]
horror
du bist kein gangster rapper also ich
weiß nicht wer das eingetrichtert hat
dass das cooles aber vielleicht wird das
sieht ja noch ganz nice jetzt geht's los
so was wie jetzt geht's los heißt auf
englisch let's go oder ist er doch
irgendwie sowas und auf deutsch das
einfach völlig bescheuert an aber da
kann das hormon ja nichts für freunde
wir schauen mal wie das ried jetzt
weiter losgeht beziehen was ich jetzt
endlich mal richtig losgehen weil jetzt
fängt das horror
warum
dicke hühner horror will ok du bist ein
huhn aber es geht um lippen und da
müsste man schon sagen dk schnabel aber
wir hören mal weiter ich habe die
kantinen hat und sie können wachsen
lassen
dpa ich hab mir gerade voll der musik
noch nie gegen also wir können bisher
festhalten dass das hormon eine parodie
auf den dicken lippen strong von katja
gemacht hat und eher sachlich dicke
lippen können blasen sondern das horn
sagte er dicke hühner und sie können
laxen also mal gucken was mit lachsen
gemeint ist und wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
ich streiche gerade meinen nicht
vorhandenen bad also er wiederholt die
ganze zeit dicke hühner ist behaupten ja
oder es ist eine sie das huhn wiederholt
auf jeden fall die ganze zeit dicke
lippen aber ja es ist leider noch immer
nicht vorbei ich hätte es auf meine
dummheit das moorhuhn hat ein copyright
auf seine dummheit wow
das
das kann doch von mir stammen hat ja
ihre schönheit weit kommt noch der macht
seien
ja
die hochzeit
ich und katja sollen obwohl das ist das
horror hunde dann ist es ja noch okay
freunde aber jetzt kommen wir zur
letzten szene des videos
zusammenfassend kann man sagen dass das
komplette lied einfach eine komplette
augenweide ist man eine feier das
musikvideo es ist mega kuhlmann danced
mit man hat die muss man spürt die
edition hesse kommt laut scheiße ehrlich
gesagt horror und tut mir echt leid
das würde ich auch sagen freunde denn
bei so einer tollen parodie von dicke
lippen katja von horror hund kann man
einfach nur einen daumen hoch geben
schaffen wir 50.000 likes für die wir
jetzt wo die aller zeiten
also wir wissen alle mittlerweile dass
bei diesem format luca reagiert wirklich
häufig sehr dumme videos zugewendet
werden wie beispielsweise in diesem fall
ein mädchen was einfach dumm tanz da
frage ich mich jetzt allerdings weil wer
bisher gerade schon vorhin auf die
parodie von dicke lippen katar reagiert
haben und uns das angesehen haben würde
dieser tanz eventuell auf die parodie
von hoffnungen passen also jetzt schauen
wir uns einmal das tanzen mädel an mit
dem horror 100 im hintergrund
[Musik]
wir wir schauen uns einfach im nächstes
video an
ganz ganz großes kino
ein logo geklaut naja gut in einer
gewissen form ist es ein smiley und voll
viele unternehmen haben ein smiley als
logo und jedes kind mal täglich in der
schule ist laut geht das wir brauchen
einen store sich kommen zu euch gefahren
und scheint euch vor die tür
doch männer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ihren frauen an der stelle wie auch im
letzten jahr reagiert video am ersten
sechs lounge meine neue kollektion
als ich vor einer woche locker reagiert
hochgeladen habe waren es noch zwei
wochen bis zum ersten sex
jetzt ist sca noch eine woche ich glaube
sogar noch ein bisschen mehr als eine
woche und ich werde euch die nächsten
tage mal die ganzen klamotten vorstellen
also viele fragen sich ja immer hey was
kommt jetzt überhaupt ein shop m das
werde ich euch die nächsten tage mal in
dem video vorstellen also keine sorge er
ist der sechste 15 uhr kann man sich
schon mal ein kalender eintragen
was ist falsch mit dir
so keinen scheiß wenn wir uns einfach
mal das hier anschauen und popelka okay
vielleicht bin ich selber ein bisschen
komisch haben wir hin
bist du dumm
bist du dumm nein schreibt man die
kommentare wenn ihr euch noch an essen
ist gut für die gesundheit ändern könnte
ich weiß das ist irgendein teil war
irgendwie mal auch hier in einem luca
reagiert hat mir das einmal eingeschickt
er wirklich überhaupt kein deutsch
konnte dieses format ist einfach so die
geburtsstätte von allen insidern auf
meinem kanal also alpakas pizza lukas
stinkt es ist gut für die kissen
tomatensaft alles rudolf luca reagiert
also freunde folgt wenn man auf twitter
ich habe davon zwar nichts aber dann
könnt ihr beim nächsten luca reagiert
video mit dabei sein und können wir da
auch sachen einstieg ich lasse euch ja
dann immer so ein paar stunden videos
aufnehmen und ja dann kommt wieder die
komplette scheiße zusammen
bron james kobe bryant michael george
curry das sind alles riesigen namen des
basketballsports doch ich habe in meiner
community die beste basketball
spielerinnen der welt als irgendein
verein aus der nba zukunft ich kann euch
ihren twitter namen geben
[Musik]
wenn es richtig gemein videos von leuten
zu gucken die geile getränke trinken
wenn ich gerade durst habe
[Musik]
das schickt mir jemand ein video ein wir
eine taschentücher packung in slow
motion fallen lässt hier das ist also
ganz im ernst von von allen folgen luca
reagiert ist dass das krasseste video
was mir hier ein geschickt wurde
[Applaus]
ihr wisst bescheid
hier wird auch hier
bescheid
ich sie vom stuhl gefallen ich finde es
immer ultra witzig wenn leute irgendwie
musicals machen und sich dabei irgendwie
auf die fresse legen oder so aber hier
macht sie halt sogar sinnvoll verdutzten
eindruck warum nachricht warum klatsch
ich sie hat sich wahrscheinlich sogar
weh getan tut mir leid
was bist du für ein mensch
cool zehn sekunden meines lebens habe
ich gerade damit verschwendet einem
gelben papagei dabei zuzusehen wie er
nichts macht auch hier sage ich lege ich
mich gar nicht so weit aus dem fenster
aber neben dem touch tücher video ist es
auf jeden fall mein absolutes highlight
von allen folgendes her da muss ich ganz
ehrlich zugeben den bieten du da gerade
gemacht hast finde ich besser als alle
die da von bibi ja was heißt alle lieder
sind bisher nur abgemacht aber besser
als warm up war es auf jeden fall alter
ist er denn so
ja cooles edit war luca zieht schleim
aus einer dose wir packen sein gesicht
rüber und luca tut selbst findet er sich
selbst ekelhaft ja es war so lustig
anders stelle sich das heute ist
allerdings ob enden meine damen und
herren es kam wirklich wieder so
unfassbar viele videos an von euch auf
twitter falls in der nächsten folge die
karriere geht auch mit dabei sein wollt
schaut und die beschreibung da steht
mein twitter und auch instagram und
snapshot und alles mögliche steht da
unten drin freunde wenn euch das
gefallen hat das gerne ein like das
schaffen wir 60.000 leicht das ist eine
sehr große summe für sein video was
eigentlich so normales format ist auf
meinem kanal aber vielleicht schafft es
ja es wird mich auf jeden fall sehr
freuen uns sonst will ich an der stelle
ist einfach nur noch sagen